[Music]
welcome back to chest opening explained
today I will be your host and we're
going to go over a line in the caro-kann
starts after E 4 c 6 d 4 D 5 and now
instead of the standard Knight to c3 92
or or e5 we're actually going to take on
d5 so now we're in the exchange and
after c4 we go into the panic Botvinnik
attack so this opening has been try for
quite a while this game that I'm going
to go over is from the 1996 I believe a
World Championship between gotta calm
ski and Anatoly Karpov and in this game
calm ski found a quite a reasonable
advantage out of the opening and managed
to convert it into a 1 so let's see how
we did Howie how we did it
so 9 of 6 is the main move adding
another defender to this d5 fun after 93
attacking again in this game black chose
to play e6 which is the most popular
move so just defending the pond one more
time so you don't have to worry about it
the other moves are going to go over are
actually Knight to c6 here and even g6
has been tried but in the in the world
change and shift Karpov chose C 6 and so
how do you think White's going to play
what do you think is plans are going to
be in this position
yeah we could attack on the queenside
yet playing c5 is actually really common
idea and this opening but the line I'm
going to recommend is actually well
first Knight f3 it should be 4 and here
we're going to actually take on d5 so
this goes into what's known as an
isolated Queens pawn position
so here White's going to be planning for
activity and Black's going to be playing
to trade off some pieces and take
advantage of the weakened d4 pawn
because it is isolated so after Knight
takes d5 obviously Black has a threat so
how should white try to solve this
yeahjust Bishop d2 the simplest moves
sometimes correct
um Queen to b3 and Queen to see if you
also seem okay but really we want to be
creating some some threats of moving
this Knight right away we want to be
able to play Knight to e4 soon if we
want or or night somewhere else maybe
maybe Knight takes d5 could be a threat
in some line and I at Bishop do d2
actually just gets the bishop out and
it's a good move all around so after
Knight to c6 putting some pressure on d4
white quickly develops his pieces black
decides to retreat his bishop because he
didn't quite like being opposite White's
bishop like this and the bishop really
just belongs on e7 to do some defensive
defensive tasks like controlling g5 for
after after black is castled because for
example what do you think might happen
if black were to Castle here right away
yeah Bishop takes h7 the classic Greek
gift sacrifice and black would find
himself in some and some serious trouble
here she's not careful so to avoid this
black goes ahead and plays sorry black
of Evan plays Bishop to e7 here
controlling g5 so the sacrifice is not
possible
so after castles and castles how do you
think white continued to build up his
pressure yep
for moving a fish applies in the opening
well by playing Bishop to b4 first it
forces white to put it as bishop on d2
which is obviously not the optimal
square this also sort of interferes with
the Queen's defense of d4 and it you
know it makes it a bit harder to control
after something like nine to c6 and yes
so the idea is black wasted some time
with Bishop to b4 but White's also
wasted some time with bishop DD - and
kind of misplaced his pieces so after
Bishop back to e7 and castles now white
actually wants to continue with Queen to
e2 so already White's looking to set up
threats on the h7 square and here a few
moves have been tried but Karpov had a
definite favorite so one idea in the
past has been to actually just try to
kick this bishop away and set up some
threats along the d4 pawn but here white
can actually gambit his pawn with
something like Bishop to e4 so after
black takes and white takes back what do
you think white can play here to really
show how his pieces are much superior to
Black's to get compensation
yeah just getting a rook to d1 and
already there are threads set up along
this Queen so black will have to move it
away and now we keep developing with
tempo we get our Bishop to a better
square Bishop to e3 Queen moves again
we misplace blacks Knight and 4 flex
Queen all the way over to e5 and after 2
c1 black is up upon but it's it's clear
whose pieces are going to be superior
and I think White has more than
sufficient compensation in this line and
Karpov agreed so Karpov instead chose to
play the move Knight to f6
trying to make it a bit harder for white
pieces to get coordinated because now
the move Queen to few Queen to e4 which
white wants to play is obviously not as
good now that it loses loses tonight
takes e4 so here white played an
interesting move obviously black is made
threat which is this pawn on d4 is
attacked twice and only defended one so
Tomsky actually found a way to defend it
through tactical means rather than just
placing peeks that defends the pawn so
what do you think Pompey found here
which piece desync in blacks army is
controlling the most pivotal squares out
of all of black pieces one is really
holding the position together yes yes
the knight on f6 it's preventing statics
on h7 it's preventing white from pushing
its pawn it's preventing white Queen
from getting to the right square so how
can we misplace this Knight
yes Oh g4 is a bit ambitious I don't
think we want to weaken our Queen
yeah nice that you force them who I'm
looking for so this move kind of
indirectly defends d4 by setting up
larger threats so obviously black is not
interested in taking money for and
getting White Queen into the game but
the what do you think might happen if
black were to accept the pawn okay so
yeah we could take on f6 and then if
black simply recaptures
Queeny for and black will play g6 just
to the fun to make threat
which Knight takes Knight yeah Knight
takes d4 Queen takes d4 and and yet no
Bishop to c3 so sorry we're threatening
to a ruined black pawn structure so
black might try Queen to d8 just holding
on
and yet we can actually take on f6 and
get our rook to d1 so black will again
have to respond to this threat if you
play something like Queen to b6 you're
again going to be hanging f6 and that's
not something you're interested in doing
something like Queen to e7 and maybe
I'll play Queen to e4 and think about
some more attacking ideas so black might
try Bishop to d7 and here we can play
Queen e4 g6 and Bishop e5 and already
black is cracking under the pressure and
has to give up and sacrifices Queen so
d4 is definitely not a pawn Black's
interested in taking because it leads to
a way too much activity for white and it
actually kind of loses tactically if you
go through all of the lines so here
instead of taking d4 black played the
reasonable Bishop to d7
which maybe instead blacks should have
tried to find the better square first
Queen on b6 but so Bishop to d7 is okay
and now how do you think why continued
did we start doing some stuff on h7 or
did we just get more pieces in the game
what do you think it's time for attack
how my each try starting your attack
night fg5 that's certainly interesting
move I believe in the game gotta got his
rook into the game which I think I'm a
fan of here what if black were to just
play h6 simple enough
yeah just night kicks night I'll
recapture night work and I pack the f3
again and now maybe I'll take your pawn
ah
elke you've tricked me you've tricked me
all right maybe I won't take your pawn
maybe instead I'll play something like
Queen b6 Bishop c3 all right I think so
yeah this is obviously okay for white
but uh but I think white found a bit
better in the game by just getting his
his rook involved with her KD one all
right and black continue now with Rick
fifty-eight getting his York in the game
white continued by bringing his other
work to the e-file and after Knight to
d5 black shows that he wants to keep
this night around because any trades on
e4 only helped white by activating its
Queen and on d5 it's stopping this pawn
from advancing any further so that was a
reasonable decision so how do you think
white again tried to evict blacks most
important piece which I'll give you a
hint is this knight on d5
yeahjust night back to c3 the night has
done its job on e4 it a tactically
defended d4 and force to collect
irresponsible threats and now it's
simply comes back to c3 and Black is
again forced to come back to f6 making
no progress alright so now I think white
responded with Bishop sorry a3 and now
one of the one of the important ideas in
the game Bishop to g5 so which square do
you think is most important and isolated
queen pawn position yeah that's right
the square in front of the pawn so here
White's idea is pretty simple he wants
to trade off this Bishop which is in
controlling d5 for this Knight which is
controlling g5 and then he wants to push
his pawn through and create some more
tactical opportunities by opening up the
position so black maybe should have
should have smelt the danger and this
piece is actually a bit weak on this
file with these pieces bearing bearing
down on it so maybe something like Rick
apke ei8 was necessary but in the game
black actually played Queen to a5 so
what do you think White's should try
here gets kind of wild
yeah that's right we're getting we're
just going to shove d5 in okay and what
happens on the most natural Knight takes
d5
yep just Knight takes d5 he takes d5 and
we've won a bishop or have we what
happens after rook e8
yeah you have Bishop to b4 and if
tonight takes before we have 864 and if
you take our queen we'll take your queen
and white would simply want a piece so
instead a black responded with a takes
d5 immediately and now what do you think
white can try
how do we justify d5 here yeah we simply
take on f6 Bishop takes f6 and oh sorry
I shouldn't have given away the secret
for a second I thought why did play
Knight takes d5 but actually stronger
here's is the sacrifice when after rook
takes d5 a lot of pieces are coming
towards blacks King and so black has to
be very careful and there's also a
tactically winning threat here so why
does rook takes d5 when white piece back
do you guys see well yeah the bishops
hanging but what if I defend it yeah
Queen to d3 is a check and a double
attack on the bishop so here black kind
of gave in and decided to try for a
fortress draw after something like
Bishop takes c3 when after rook takes a5
Bishop a5 black is is trying to hold
with the rook and the bishop for the
Queen so way actually I should mention
right now black has a rook and two
bishops for a queen so how are we going
to win our piece back
check on d3 King g8
yeah you do have a problem still so we
have to insert a move first yeah just be
for preventing the attack on a rook with
tempo so black chose to say that is a
LightSquared Bishop I believe with King
to g8 stepping out of the fork and so
white takes back on 85 and now we've got
a really interesting endgame where a
white had to push for 40 more moves to
break through actually so let's see how
we did that quickly so Bishop to g4
putting the knight a six trying to break
down blocks pawn so black goes head and
except this and now comes the fortress
position so what black wants to do is
set as rooks up on the sixth rank
defending this night and just claim he
can hold forever so let's see how that
went for them after it to e8 choose a
good question do you think white should
trade rooks or should he try to keep
them on somehow okay so why do you think
it'd be easier to break through if you
keep the rooks on because you get on the
seventh rank
yeah so in the game god I actually
wanted to keep his work on the board
because if we trade here for example and
remove the made threat
something like rq6 like you mentioned
actually is pretty strong and it's tough
to create mating threats on blacks King
with only your queen I would say white
is probably still winning here but it
just takes a lot a lot more effort I
think you might have to push your pawns
down the border to create some mating
threats but with the rook on the board
it's actually a lot easier for white to
try to threaten the blacks King here
without too much difficulty so how can
white go about saving his rook well if
you play risk to c1 it we actually have
Knight to d4 attacking the Queen and the
rook so yeah in the game gotta actually
played the funny-looking earth-2 a1 to
escape so black continues Rick to e6
setting up this fortress white remove
the may threat and after d8 Queen to c3
and now there was a lot of maneuvering
and I'll just flip through it quickly
because white didn't actually make
progress for quite a while here so yeah
it just shuffling around making a few
threats here and there and then White's
actual plan comes into play here so
White's going to try to gain some space
using these pawns and try to make these
drugs more awkward because right now all
of black's pieces are tied down this
Knight is tied down to the defense of
these two pawns and these rooks are tied
down to the to the defense of this
Knight so black really can't allow
himself to get into something like as up
lose WOM so here he decided he had to
play g6 and to just trade off this F
pawn once it gets to f5 so white went
ahead and played at five and now after G
takes f what is white achieve
yeah he's opened up blacks King so now
it's much much easier for white to break
through by threatening some checkmating
ideas using the trick in this Queen now
that the King has no shelter so yeah
like you mentioned white can actually
take backs because technically this rook
will be hanging if black were to
recapture here so black again shuffles
and white brings his rook to the h-file
so now he's threatening something like
Queen to c8 and clean the h8 with
checkmate
so black plays Rick to h6 to stop this
after Queen to g3 check King f8 rooks to
d5 Erik jisuk green f2 eventually white
pulls together an actual threat so here
white I believe played Queen c7 King f8
and now after Queen to c8 black began to
falter
so obviously you can't block this check
because the knight is hanging so the
king is forced to come up to e7 and
after rook to d4 to d5 threatening
something like Queen d7 King King to f6
stepping out of the way
Queen to h8 and now White has achieved a
disconnection of black pieces as well as
this pin on blacks York which will end
up being devastating after the e4 simply
route to h5 Knight to e7 and we just add
more pressure to the attack piece and
there's no way for black to save as'
piece and so here black resigns so the
important thing to take note of was
obviously got a confit it's very
impressive that breaking down fortresses
and then in the opening you want to see
how got to use these these tactical
ideas to defend its D pawn now it wasn't
afraid to sacrifice it in some lines and
how you want to use your pieces to
create threats along along
can fled like this so again the
important square to control is d5 and
the important piece for black is always
this knight on f6 you want to do
everything you can to either misplace or
trade off this night for one of your
inferior pieces and then you get a lot
more threats a lot more easily we're
here we're going to look at a slightly
different opening variation so in the
previous game of course would be started
off from the starting position and the
pan of we played Knight to c4 they
played nice f6 we played nine to c3 and
anatoly karpov responded with pawn to e6
in this game we're actually going to
look at what happens if black plays
Knight to c6 so rather than a taking the
time to defend this pawn more blacks
trying to create counter threats on d4
by threatening something like D takes d4
and Queen takes d4 so in the olden days
people very often played Knight to f3
and we went into what's called the
endgame line in the caro-kann so in a
very long and complicated line or not
too complicated I guess so I already
messed up black ends up in an endgame
where his King is a bit worse but
White's pawn structure is a bit messed
up and so that occurs after something
like like this I believe and the actual
move order is flipping my mind here rook
c8 I don't
hmm Queen CA doesn't seem quite right
it's unimportant anyways it's a boring
endgame line and no one wants to play
those so I'm recommending the more
active Fischer to g5 here so what this
does is again like in the previous game
where we want to control the d5 square
so why is immediately threatening to
trade off this night and to simply take
on d5 winning upon so black is a few
ways to respond to this in this game
Topa log shows blacksmith popular move
which is Bishop to e6 defending the D
pawn again and threatening to capture on
c4 in some lines but black can also try
do you take c4 so let's look at this
quickly here white has a couple
different options you could simply
recapture his pawn or you could play the
more active pawn to d5 but the simplest
I think is just Bishop to c4 the pawn to
d5 lines are by no means bad but black
has a pretty good reputation here to
consolidate and equalize after something
like quick d4 and something like h6 you
start to realize you can't keep all your
pieces on these active squares and
something like Bishop h4 something like
this has been tried quite often and
black white gets the pawn on d6 and some
lines but then it's difficult to keep it
after something like 97 and Knight to d5
and blocking off the file hanging taking
advantage of this pen so those lines are
very complicated and you're welcome to
study them on your own but I'm just
going to recommend Bishop to c4 when
you'll develop your Knight to f3 and
Castle kingside and get a similar iqp
position isolated Queens pawn as the
previous game but like I said in the
game black chose the slightly more
popular Bishop to e6 so in the game
white actually just continued
development with Knight to f3 so does
anyone see why D takes c4 isn't such a
red
yeah origin that's right we can fork
blacks pieces with Bishop take that six
he takes f6 and d5 with a double attack
on the pieces and black is no way to
save the piece here so black wants to
threaten to take c4 with something like
h6 so do you guys see why Bishop h4
might not be a great move now that we
use ya origin
yeah g5 which is looks pretty weakening
but actually after Bishop g3 and you
take c4 black has the d5 square well on
the control and there's no way for white
to regain this pawn immediately and this
would be pretty good for blood so
because of that white actually took on
f6 in this game straight away so after a
takes f6 again we want to control the d5
square and now that we've traded off
their dark squared Bishop we want to
play against these this fractured pawn
structure so I continued with a3 and why
do you think Bishop to e2 which looks
like the most natural way to develop
wasn't played
why would white choose a three instead
yeah Arjun okay pawn takes pawn well
again we have this d5 move forking the
pieces
night before doesn't really threaten
anything
why would Bishop before be good move
why do you think yet pins the night but
I'll simply castle yes so you can play
Bishop c3 and what does what does this
actually do here you take and then you
yeah you can take the pawn and black
straight off is dark squared Bishop for
our Knight that controlled d5 and
remember a lot of these isolated Queens
pawn or even even other pawn structures
all revolve around controlled the d5
square so that's what black and white
should both be playing for in this game
so that's why white actually chose the
strange-looking a3 because you wanted to
cement this knight on c3 where it
controlled b5 as well as prepared to
expand on the Queen side if that's the
dual purpose to the moon but the reason
we had to play it first was because of
Bishop b4 so black instead develops to
e7 white dillos 282 castles and castles
so here a black went ahead and played f5
so maybe he wants to bring this Bishop
to f6 and put some more pressure on the
steep on as well as cements his control
of the e4 square so where do you think
whites should be playing now in the
previous game we looked at in iqp where
White was trying to attack the King but
now we've seen that black has quite a
few quite a few pawns so it might be
difficult
yet we could play for the e5 square but
in general where should we be trying to
find our play yeah on the queenside
so white actually went ahead and started
with Queen c2 and after Bishop f6 rook
to d1 g6 and now we go ahead and start
our expansion with b4 so White's plan
might be to make a strong count on c5
and just push these pawns down the board
so black needs to find a way to stop
this so what do you chose in the game is
pawn to a6 for the moment preventing
anything coming to b5 it kind of not Y
could still play pawn to b5 to see once
but it's a bit weakening and it opens up
the rug for this for this a file so that
might not be the best idea instead white
chose Bishop to f1 revealing his rook
and like Arjun said taking control of e5
black continued with f4 trying to set up
some threats on the Kings side yes what
do you want to play it's kind of like a
Kings Indian kind of reversed but not
not exactly it's as if there are a few
extreme differences such as this pawn
being on d5 and not e5 and I wouldn't
call it a king's indian structure but so
what do you think white played here
because blacks let's move up for kind of
came with a threat not a threat to win
material but a threat to make white
pieces awkward and to try to mess with
their communications the c5 what do you
think black might play if we played a
natural move like c5 that's what I'm g5
not quite not quite yet Bishop to f5
could be an idea the move I was thinking
of was actually Bishop to g4 with this
kind of annoying pin
and it's kind of tough for white to
actually deal with it because if you
play something like earth to d3 what do
you think black has yeah you can just
take the knight and then take on D take
on d4 so white actually felt the need to
stop the threat with the move pawn to h3
so black continued with D takes e4 now
you can finally prevent white from his
plan of bringing pawn to c5 so what
wouldn't White's plan against B takes d4
this entire game it was p5 right let's
take a look at what happens after g5 why
is black okay here
that's right Bishop to f5 so gaining a
temple on White Queen and stepping out
of the fork so after Queen to c1
attacking that's up pawn black played
Knight to e7 preparing to reroute to
this b v square and after Knight to d4
white black played the very natural
Bishop d7 because he didn't want to
triplets pawn so what do you think white
played here there are a few tempting
options
a4 there are two pawns hanging and you
want to play for it's okay
slow good a4 makes them sense
positionally but they're more more
pressing matters at hand
Queen take that forward that's those are
all good options but White has something
even stronger here and once you see it
you'll be blown away
not quite Bishop takes e4 not quite nice
to eat for not quite it's not quite it's
White's time
it's not d6 although that is a good idea
giving you your piece of d5 square but
there's a tactical shot here
not quite nice EEE - all of these moves
probably are okay for white white has a
pretty okay position here but so there's
something that is very very convincing
yeah that's it
96 BAM checking the whole family and
what might happen after Queen takes up
foreign stuff let's take a look so I
think black might actually just straight
away play Knight to d5 and after a trade
he actually has some serious pressure on
this a pawn and it might get pretty
awkward for white to defend so it's
important that White has with the shot
Knight to e6 check here because now what
happens after F takes e6 trying to win
the piece yeah tante c6 and we have the
pin so in the game black actually tried
to defend with Bishop takes c6 do you
take c6 and Queen to c8 and all right
let's see what can we play here to try
to keep the attack going
be seven get you seven looks okay but
maybe black will simply play rook to e8
stopping the pawn in his tracks yet rook
to d7 so actually defending this pawn by
pinning it and increasing the pressure
on blacks King
so black continued with King to h8
stepping out of the pen and now what do
you think white shows here yeah Queen
takes up or very good so what happens
with Bishop c3 Queen h6 King g8 pawn f7
or Cup 7 all right Eric g7 am i
defending yeah rook to e8 but I can
simply take it right
so yeah rook e8 and then Bishop c4 I
think actually the correct is to do it
in the other order if we take a look
here this might still be winning I
didn't actually check this line but it
should be yeah I think this is actually
mating that's not me
are you sure so yeah after at age seven
this would be mate so you have a good
point but maybe I can play King to f8
and hold on
somehow rook f7 I'll take it Queen d6
Queen up five I'm planning on blocking
the check at the rook either way and
okay you win all right fair enough let's
say yeah the points is blacks not taking
this night because of Queen h6
so instead black played Bishop to g7
defending h6 defending it's bishop and
now what's the move do you guys think
yeah rook takes f7 I believe so
so we're still increasing the pressure
we've taken that seven pawn and now
we're threatening to continue with a
seven so after Queen to c6 we go ahead
and continue with E 754 after work - II
ate can anyone find find the winning
idea here on I see five that might be
okay but I think we had something a bit
better service I'm not Bishop takes
before maybe you were actually losing
your ear night then yeah rook to e6 I'll
play Queen 87 okay yeah rook to g6 seems
pretty good maybe I can survive by
taking this night where it takes pawn
fate okay that'll work
the earth takes g6 looks good in the
game white actually chose Knight to d5
with the threat of Knight to f6 but so
I'm sure everything wins here Rick to g6
I guess I guess I actually have to play
Queen to d4 to hold on but yeah then
just Queen takes rook and obviously this
is this is winning so everyone gets a
gold star for for winning the game in
multiple ways but sigh yes so the main
points to keep track of well first of
all black had a better move here and he
actually just had to let his pawns get
tripled rather than playing Bishop to d7
and allowing this attack because this
attack was just unstoppable and then he
finds some counter play along this aid
file and it'll be a game so yeah the
main thing is to keep track of are the
battle for the d5 square white always
wanted to be sure he had the option to
play pawn to d5 whenever black took on
c4 and basically blacks plan is to
expand on the Kings side and White's
plan is to
and on the queenside when you get this
pawn structure like this does that make
sense so the last game we're going to
look at involves a third line so
previously we looked at after this
position we looked at e6 and then we
looked at Knight to c6 and now we're
going to look at what happens if black
develops as bishops along another
diagonal so here he wants to be putting
pressure on this d4 square and maybe
playing something like e five in the
future to try to open it up so what do
you think White's plan might be now that
black took a slower approach and is not
immediately putting pressure with this
knight on d4 or immediately defending
this pawn on d5 what do you think well I
can try Bishop to g5 makes them sense
it's probably probably a move but the
something even more direct just adding
pressure immediately to the d5 pawn yes
so the move we're going to look at today
is actually okay so yeah I think Queen
to b3 so right away we're putting more
pressure on this pawn so what do you
think happens if black takes with D
takes e4 yeah just Bishop to c4 and then
you're forced to do something like e6
and now how can white break through
right away to get a good position
yeah d5 because of what black flow
approach white can actually just break
through d5 and blacks King finds
themselves in quite a bit of trouble
after something like this and b7 will
hang and we can take here and take here
and none of it looks pretty for black so
because of this black isn't likely to
take on on c4 and instead in the game he
chose Bishop to g7 and now White's game
plan is actually just be really really
annoying okay so it seems like after C
takes D black should be able to regain
this pawn somehow
simply bring the night out or play b6
and Bishop d7 and really just bear down
on this pawn the black or excuse me
White's plan is to just defend it and
ask like what is he doing because I have
a strong d5 pawn and you're down
material so how can white go about
enacting this plan where should he put
all his pieces bishop on c4 okay that's
one way where do you think there's some
nice going to head yet f3 on there's
actually a better square foot than f3 so
yeah the square we're aiming for is
actually on f4 so if we try to get
through there through h3 maybe black can
play Bishop takes h3 so yeah I hear you
saying it nice at you - oh it's blacks
turn so yeah we're actually going to
play Knight Knight G - E - that's right
so we're aiming for f4 where we can
defend this pawn right and then instead
of on c4 where do you think might be a
better Square for the bishop yeah we're
going to head to g2 we're going to get
on the long diagonal and really defend
this pawn so black continues with Knight
B to d7 trying this ideas night to b6
and putting pressure here so I continues
with its plan just g3 Knight b6 and
Bishop g2 we're in time to defend the
pawn so now black plays Bishop f5 just
heating getting developed white will
castle and now black plays Queen to d7
so we plan to put even more pressure on
d5 so here white continued with rook to
d1 putting his rook on the D file just
supporting his it spawns after excuse me
Rick to d8 we went ahead and played
Knight to f4 so now all of our pieces
that can defend d5 are defending d5 so I
think we've completed our plan here
do you think g5 would be a good move for
black here that's my question to you why
not right so g5 is actually playable but
it does leave some serious weaknesses
for black so first of all the sign is
going to be way too strong an e5 or c5
the black should probably take it and
then after something like h6 defending
the spawn it's true that you're going to
win d5 but you're going to have to
struggle for it as after something like
d6 opening up our bishop and boozing d5
on our terms
CT take D we're actually going to
immediately play h4 and if you take
it'll open up the G file which I'm well
prepared prepared for it'll weaken h6
and if you don't take g5 is going to
fall so black really isn't doing well
here
which is why in the game black opted for
a move other than g5 he actually just
went ahead with h6 so now that blacks
kind of threatening g5 up a tempo
compared to the other line what you
think White's right here yeah just pawn
to h4 cementing this knight on f4 right
in the front d5 so what has been pretty
much the common scheme in all of these
different lines
yeah the d5 square which is really what
White's
aiming for straight out of the opening
with taking on d5 and then challenging
it right away with pawn to c4 so
whenever you play any of these lines
that's really what you want to keep in
mind is controlling the d5 square and
making sure your opponent doesn't gain
control so here in the game black just
brought us rook out and white played a
four so what do you think the ideas of
a4
yeah when I kicked the night to a bad
square and then we actually might want
to play a six in weekend black's pawn
structure so whenever an opponent or
your opponent put the night on be six
and in different openings a night off
and ends up on g6 a really strong idea
can just be to push the wing pawn and
put put the night off center so here
black played Knight to c4 trying to step
out of the way before or it became a
problem and now that black has released
some pressure on d5 white wants to
improve one of those pieces so what do
you think white trade will actually I
think white played a five and after B
six white went ahead and look and now
how can we tactically win upon here
rook wear rook a four maybe I can just
well that might technically went upon
the move I was looking for was actually
bishops f1 but let's look at a Rick to a
score for a second here what might black
try
something like b5 maybe maybe like could
just take it might be the issue and then
maybe black can try night to b6 however
and recapture on on d5 like this then
have a strong thank yous hmm Bishop c2
yet that as well so white will have to
respond to all these threats probably
with Knight c3 and then uh yeah the rook
is also hanging so there's a bit better
way to to handle this and I think that
Bishop to f1 simply came to keeping the
rook back here not stepping into any
tricks along this diagonal with bishops
at c2 so black is forced to retreat his
night and now Queen takes b6 and White's
actually had two pawns so he has this be
pawn and an extra double D pawn so the
cos b6 which looks natural it wanted to
get a white strong Colin out of here and
and give us Knight ask where it actually
loses the pawn but maybe better for
black would have been to play Knight to
e8 just simply rerouting aiming for the
d6 square the game might have continued
something like 92 d3
improving improving our Knights Knight
to d6 965 and Queen to d7 when why it
has quite a bit of play with something
like Knight to d5 or something like 86
but the it's at least a game because
blacks not going to be down to entire
con but instead black tried b6 and now
white is simply simply have to pawn so
black opted for rook to c7 trying to vex
White Queen eventually with work to b7
and bring together to c8 maybe or to b8
and white improves his his worst piece
in my opinion now that this Knight is no
longer pressuring the d5 square we can
afford to move it to a better Square on
e5 or c5 and black afraid of those
Knight moves actually decided to trade
it off so after Bishop d3 Bishop d3
there - b7 attacking the Queen Queen to
a5 simply coming back preparing to get
the
Queen back on sides there to b8 King to
g2 blacks pieces are really going
nowhere so why it takes time and
prevents any Queen h3 ideas
h5 Queen a4 again trying to come back
Queen to d8 Queen to c2 Queen back to d7
black is really just shuffling it's
tough to find the reasonable plan for
him so this is maybe the best you can do
Queen to e2 putting pressure on this
epon may be threatening something like
Queen to f3 so just support even more on
d5 after rooks to be for attacking this
be pawn white played Bishop c2 to defend
it
Queen to b7 Queen Queen to f3 cling back
to c7 and now white finally aims to make
some progress after improving his piece
as much as they reasonably could be
improved
he tries her to a6 so he wants to come
into c6 and really start putting some
pressure on on blacks pieces here so
black plays Knight to g4 putting even
more pressure on this D pawn worked at
c6 Queen to d7 and now white companion
with Knight to e2 simply defending and
after Knight to h6 trying to find a
better Square for this night on f5 where
he can again pressure the d4 pawn which
was really his plan from the beginning
which she's a bit late getting to you
now but he wants to open up this bishop
by putting pressure on d4 so what do you
think White's right here Bishop h6
actually not quite so we do want to get
this Bishop out but so the way we need
to do it is by defending this be pawns
first so we try pawn to b3 aiming for
this diagonal so after Knight to f5
Bishop to b2 we need to defend our pawn
rook back to p7 work to a1 trying to get
our last piece in the game and actually
repeating when a black attacks the
square
so now Bishop to c3 preventing her to be
for preparing roof to a-1 so black wants
to get on the file before white and
white actually Obstetricians pieces were
Fundy one for one of blacks defenders
and now after Queen to a7 Bishop c3
black is actually finally taking on d4
so how do you think white should
continue here which pieces should he
trade and which pieces should he keep on
okay so let's trade nine I agree
the supplied squared bishop is too
important and then should we take again
on d4 no we really shouldn't we have the
strong double bishops and that we don't
want to activate blacks Queen anymore so
white instead chose Bishop to d2 black
decided to bring his bishop back as it
it looked nice on d4 but he really can't
do any constructive plans with it so he
brings it back to ship to e3 push it
back to d4 just blocking black is really
hoping to make a draw here he shoots
down upon so he's offering why all the
repetitions and after Bishop f4 he tried
to repeating again with Bishop to g7 but
this is actually losing a pawn on d6 so
this is how the game continued if black
were to instead try to hang on to the
pawn with something like Queen to d7
white would end up winning it anyways I
think after Queen to d3 attacking the
bishop bishop back and Queen to a6 when
it's really tough to the fun this night
if you were to play something like her
to dat maybe I could just start pushing
my pawn down the board and if you were
to try something like going to be 7 this
is probably your best bet and you get a
similar position except the Queen's are
off the board so white can't as easily
make any progress here by threatening
blacks King and and using this Queen to
assist and pushing the pawn forward this
was probably blacks best try I'm not
convinced he's going to be able to hold
this position but probably the best that
he could do
but instead we saw black play Bishop g7
here and white went ahead and took this
pawn and after Queen d7
worked at c6 rook to e8 Bishop to e3 and
Bishop to e5 trying to hold on the dark
squares with this setup here so after
Bishop to d6 white played a really
interesting move here so how do you
think white can quickly make progress
using some tactical means this is why it
was a bit better for white to have the
Queen's on because these threats are
always lurking in the position
so what would white try to do if he were
allowed and black couldn't do anything
what is White's plan yeah you want to
get this pawn to the end of the board so
how can we go about doing that Queen c3
not quite this the Starks squared
blockade would remain strong so what
were to happen if black were to play
rook to b8 here do you think why it has
any yeah Arjun yeah you have vertex g 6
if F takes G 6 we have D 6 check winning
black Queen right so we see this threat
and now is there any way we can use that
tactic to our advantage here yeah we can
just play d4 right away and black is
powerless to stop us because if Bishop
takes b4 we have the same idea with our
cakes g6 up to 6 and d6 so instead in
the game black played the rook to a8
trying to get some active defense on the
3rd rank or the first drink maybe
depending on what white place Y
continued pushing is pawn rook to a1
Queen to e3 on now is the time to play a
Queen III trading off the Queens now
that our pawns are a bit more advanced
it's really tough for black to stop them
after your Queen III at b3 this should
be v d6 really getting far down the
board now and here d6 King to g7
stepping off the back rank where a white
shirt could check to support a pawn
promotion here black or white side pawn
to d7 and after rook to d1 what's the
winning move for white Arjen rook c7 not
quite not quite this does look good
I think maybe maybe this is winning as
well
king de f 8 would be would be my guess
trying to hold on with King here in here
it's not too too complicated a tactic
but it gets the job done
yeah it's simply rook to c5 preparing
Rick to d5 and if black were to take of
course this is the winning endgame
so here black actually resigns if you
were to try something like Bishop's f6
grip to d5 takes takes and there's no
way for blacks to stop both of these
pawns so again the very important square
in this game turned out to be d5 right
white put all of his pieces on squares
where they could attack this attack this
pawn or defend this pawn so that's
really what's important to keep in mind
so in all these lines black tried to
control d5 and white managed to stop him
so keep in mind the d5 square when you
play the panel Botvinnik attack all
right well thank you guys for watching I
hope you enjoyed
[Music]
you
[Music]